how you doing good people on Dave Rubin
this is the Rubin report we have a TYT
all-star panel Ben mankiewicz Jimmy Dore
I think you know these guys so let's get
right to it Jimmy I appreciate the wave
to the people they like that people like
to delineate between men do you want to
give a wave or any sort of
acknowledgement of the enemy
I would like you to take the one shot of
Dave for a quick second because I do
like the rub rep will do that's how we
finish up that show you're gonna be on
that show I am the rub rep so Edward
Snowden was interviewed by Brian
Williams for the NBC Nightly News and he
laid a couple bombs I mean huge breaking
news we've got two clips for you let's
take a look at the first I was trained
as a spy and sort of the traditional
sense of the word and that I lived and
worked undercover overseas pretending to
work in a job that I'm not and even
being assigned a name that was not mine
but I am a technical specialist I am a
technical expert I don't work with
people I don't recruit agents what I do
is I put systems to work for the United
States and I've done that at all levels
from from the bottom on the ground all
the way to the top okay that seems
pretty huge nobody knew about this even
President Obama was saying he was a
low-level systems analyst or a low-level
hacker everyone in the government has
been saying that whereas you can hear
more about this but this is huge right I
don't know I don't know that it's huge
it's interesting and the debate about
who Eric's of Eric Snowden that's is
that the fake name well yes they and
Edward Edward Jesus right but I find the
debate about Edward Snowden interesting
like and and I like talking about it but
it's not really important like it still
only matters what he really
still only matters what he released and
and you know and and what we're gonna do
about it like it and the debate that
comes afterwards like of course the
administration tries to minimize it so
that doesn't really it doesn't really
surprise me you know and and does it
again suppose that we find out that that
he should have that their argument could
quickly quickly shift from he's not high
enough ranking to know better to now
they could go he should have known
better yeah you know I mean I don't I
that that's why I don't it's interesting
it's it's credibly interesting I don't
know that really changes what the most
important discussions about this ought
to be yeah when you said that he dropped
two big bombs I thought it's cuz he's
eating a lot of Salvadorian food but
that wasn't the case and I like what
Brian Williams given us a serious face
which is nice but then he had to take he
didn't do a follow-up cuz he had to take
off he had an improv class over at the
UCB he had to get to right away yeah
what are we talking about Snowden yes
he's a spy
are you surprised yes because we've been
again what what what we've been told is
that this guy is a low-level he then and
I always said well if he's so low-level
how come he has access to all this
unbelievable information it turns out
because these are friggin spy and you
said but doesn't that make Obama look
bad that's right so before the show I
was saying well then how did they let
Obama keep going out there and keep
saying he's a low-level because that's
what they do they discredit so whoever
is blows gives out information that they
don't want to give out they discredit
him just like they did with Valerie
Plame and her husband when he
discredited them innit so it's just the
conspiracies happen right out in the
open and then when someone says hey this
is a thing that's happening they just
discredit him and that's exactly what
he's saying this they've been doing so
do you think Obama knew and then yes you
think someone else here maybe wait until
we get some look there's good at the the
governess the United States gonna say
something different about what is level
of spying was right I my hunch is that
there is probably a way that you can
have his if if you're to believe is a
low level position actually described
look he's a low level position who if it
is a low level position who installed
systems for the National Security
Administration to keep our secrets safe
like it's not like a low-level employee
at the Young Turks I mean like it's so
right she wasn't a janitor this way
level stuff was still pretty right so
even like my there may not even be a
difference in acknowledging what he did
it's just characterizing it like the NSA
might say listen there were his thirty
seven people to report to before he got
to the end of the NSA and he'd go I was
essentially a spy that's why like III
already see a conversation devolving
nationally about this that then I
wouldn't be that interested in like I'm
interested in his politics and what
motivated him and is he gonna get
prosecuted like that stuff interest me
again none of it is as important as what
he released and how we react to that as
a country right so as you're both saying
of course the government is gonna look
to discredit him and he addressed that
now the government might denying these
things they might frame it in certain
ways and say oh well you know he's a
low-level analyst but what they're
trying to do is they're trying to use
one position that I've had in a career
here or there to distract from the
totality of my experience which is that
I've worked for the Central Intelligence
Agency undercover overseas I've worked
for the National Security Agency
undercover overseas and I've worked for
the Defense Intelligence Agency as a
lecturer at the joint
counterintelligence training academy
where I developed sources and methods
for keeping our information and people
secure in the most hostile and dangerous
environments around the world so when
they say I'm a little level Systems
Administrator that I don't know what I'm
talking about
I'd say it's somewhat misleading I'm
obviously very Pro Snowden I'm Pro the
release of all these actions there is
something a slightly cryptic about him
right and maybe that just comes with the
job you know I was watching the sea we
watched it together CNN's take on that
they ran that clip in the CNN anchor I
can't identify but he could play an
anchorman on virtually any television
show very professional very professional
afterwards he said quote a lot of energy
he's putting into giving a sense of
importance to his position
CNN won't take a stand on climate change
right right I mean they could literally
bring someone on the network who'll did
that evolution exists but they'll take a
shot at Snowden that the first
opportunity up so I think you will see a
lot of that that said he was really into
giving himself a sense of importance
that but if you were being minimized by
other people
your natural any person's natural
response would be to say no no you're
wrong you're right we can't get too
caught up in the nuance of every little
thing he says and how he says it because
that's not what this is really about
yeah so I think that if you're a CNN
going back to your point if you're gonna
try and discredit Edward Snowden you
have to do it with facts like oh yeah he
said he was a spy turns out he wasn't
turns out he said he said he worked
overseas doing this he did it you can't
just go wow he's putting a lot of yeah
uh trying to look like he's important
well then he said what he said was false
well it's it was true everything he said
he was but that's what's [ __ ] about
that's the anything was total [ __ ]
it was a weird bit of editorializing and
there's only one response to this is you
call the DIA and the CIA and the NSA and
you say what was his job and they go
we're not telling you and then you say
by the way we call these people to see
their stone was telling the truth and
they wouldn't comment right so I'm
moving the next [ __ ] story
I'm gonna guess CNN will do that but
somebody might do that so my final
thought is you think this guy's ever
stepping foot in the US again no is
there any chance definitely not maybe if
Jimmy Carter's president again step foot
knee UI like I'm gonna just did I
there's a scenario where he sets foot in
the US and he spends a little bit of
time in jail that worked out and that's
what I do that's how I handle I put him
in jail I've never been consistent on
that I wouldn't put in that would throw
them away he's not he not a traitor
right uh but you know some of the things
he gave up were things that he should be
given up because he gave up so much
stuff it turned out there was some stuff
in there probably should have gone the
NSA stuff is incredibly important that
we all know like it put the guy in jail
for three years we could write gonna be
a federal he'd be fine
he'd write a book you get gazillionaire
after right everybody wins sometimes we
just do this ourselves you know Obama
went to Afghanistan the other day and we
accidentally outed one of our own spies
by putting them on a list of people that
run show up at Obama's event so we do it
whether Snowden's doing this or not Karl
Rove by the way goes on Fox News in
comparison to Valerie Plame's
is worse than Valerie Plame he did it
intentionally and then lies about it on
a regular basis if you're watching this
video and it's loading slowly and you're
in the United States there is a reason
why the United States is now ranked 30th
in broadband speeds and we pay more than
many other westernized nations we've got
some info for you so us download speeds
ranked behind Iceland Romania Bulgaria
France Russia the UK and many more we
also pay more an average of 55 dollars a
month for broadband service while
countries with faster connections like
some of the ones I just mentioned come
in at about $45 a month
Hong Kong which has the fastest internet
speeds in the world they pay about 40%
less than we pay about 31 bucks a month
uh I guess this shouldn't surprise us
because it seems like most of our stuff
in the United States is not working that
well our infrastructure
now our broadband um is it weird that
we're not talking about this more that
this that because everything's online
the computer it's all online should we
be more concerned about our slow ass
Internet what struck me is what I'm
curious about really after reading that
article was how many of those countries
how much government investment was been
obviously look I get it the government
invested a lot in the internet to begin
with but to keep those speeds up to date
like is it all the businesses just do it
themselves is that their motivation or
is there is that government work to make
sure because there is a vested interest
for business purposes for every purpose
that for government you've heard the
government use those guys get subsidies
from the government yeah I would imagine
that they do and we're leaving it up
pretty much two years I can tell and I'm
have all the information here but we're
leaving it up Comcast try to merge with
Time Warner which will have so many
customers you know there's no incentive
for them to update it and make sure that
we move into the top five or top ten
because when you have how many customers
they're about to have a hundred 20
million whatever it is if merger is
allowed to go through they'll control
half the countries if high-speed
Internet in the bill we need they're all
paying fifty five dollars a month we
literally we can't we don't know what to
do with all this money right so your
point it's only getting
the Time Warner Comcast thing is only
gonna make this worse and what was the
one this week DirecTV and AT&T so that
even right so it's only gonna get worse
because they have no interest because
there's so little competition well I
think Teddy Roosevelt taught us that
huge monopolies are a good thing they
did they helped our economy they helped
B or they helped the general public
everybody gets to get a piece of the pie
when one person owns everything yeah
isn't that and by the way we got to stop
calling it broadband it's 2014 it's a
woman band okay so the the glass merger
that they didn't approve the federal
government was when what was it's not
sprint but what's the other one wanted
to be taken over by anyway they did not
let one of those mergers go by which I
couldn't believe that was because one of
you say here's what if the merger is
doesn't benefit the consumers they're
not supposed to let it happen they're
not supposed to let a merger happen
because if it benefits the company but
not the consumers and that's what
happened so we're gonna get less choice
right when this merger happens when you
get less choice we're gonna get poor
service we're gonna get higher prices
yet they're gonna let this go through
because we live in a banana republic not
technically banana but I like to misuse
that term mean corrupt you're close
enough what happened to us a number one
are we number one in anything anyway
number one then but right now me we said
but we said we are number one in
bankruptcies attributed to medical care
we're number one I think any dust rise
world and infant mortality so we've got
a lot of number ones so we've got a
couple just switching number one a good
that's number one index we a lot of
those number one but back in the day and
those things were were there any there
really I guess at one point we must have
had the number one growing economy
someone growing economy in the world and
you know were were number one in war uh
you know these day about the Washington
Senators before they left town you know
uh the Washington was first in war first
in peace last in the American League
yeah and uh uh but now we're not even
not even first in peace no one no one
would know would no one would argue that
with a straight face I I worry about
like that that something like the
internet the
that that again it just feels like the
this us maintaining elite internet
speeds and status like that requires
government intervention somehow I'm not
saying they have to pay dough but then
they have to subsidize that they have to
spur well they would have to tell
Comcast hey you have to up if we're
gonna allow this merger here's the deal
by 2022 were 6th in the world make that
happen or whatever it is get the speed
up to whatever it needs to be yeah
does the government in a weird way have
a vested interest in our internet not
being that good no III that we can't
have we won't have access to information
as easily well I think benefit so what
what I think should be happening is that
the municipalities should be making
internet available to everyone for free
right because they done studies and they
figured out that the places that do that
it actually helps everyone's business if
you're able to access Wi-Fi no matter
where you are inside of a city if the
business goes up productivity goes up
tax revenue goes up so it pays for
itself it's one of those things that
helps people get kids get educated kids
can get on the internet whatever they
want at school at home on the bus no
matter what so this is it so they can
have Wi-Fi so that's what people of
course that's what we should be doing
just like health care universal health
care we should have universal Wi-Fi and
Internet access
because that helps everybody it rises on
everyone but of course we won't because
there's money in a select few people and
keeping it the way it is
so speaking of those select few people
so we've done every week we've been
doing stories on net neutrality so net
neutrality got flipped it was by an FCC
appointed guy that was an Obama campaign
bundler who also worked in the telecom
lobby is as a telecom lobbyist so
between this story and net neutrality is
the Internet as we know it really on
shaky ground right now like are we in
our last hour Mike receives on shaky
ground right now this we don't we don't
really live in an in a Bhakra see that's
where our leaders are responsive to the
their people that they are voting for
them the voters they're only responsible
to the donor class we say it all the
time and you know what happens when you
look at the gun control right we talk
about it all 90% of the people wanted
background checks we didn't get it what
do you call that what kind of government
do we have this isn't a democracy
anymore this is government by the few
for the few and of the few
bring us home all that was pretty
effective uh bringing us home I don't
think you know with that other let's
let's roll let's bring it let's take a
nice broad finish and make it much
narrower that's what we like to do
television comedy sorry uh you know the
net neutrality debate is not over
that's the good news is important keep
talking about I'm not saying that we
should be dismissed but the the FCC
commissioners seem open to at the were
in the public debate period to hearing
about it to sort of hearing and so I
don't know I'm pointlessly I'm always a
little optimistic and I think that's
ridiculous but it's not it's not signed
and sealed yet and part of it is that we
talk about it and say that that it needs
to be preserved all right there you go
let's talk about old people and sex that
makes everybody happy we're dedicating
this segment to Blanche Devereaux by the
way old people are getting more STDs
than ever we've got proof between 2011
and 2012 STI sexually transmitted
infections increased by 3% for those
between 45 and 65 and 7 percent for
those over 60 when it comes to
forgetting about safe sex we always
think of the vulnerability of young
people but there's the Fifty Shades of
Grey effect where older people are being
more explorative but not necessarily
remembering to use a condom and that's
from dr. Jones who's the chairwoman of
the British Medical Association's GP
committee so yeah go first of all uh
David pointed out that sti's is more
politically correct than STDs who was
making that argument yeah what I give
you
gonorrhea has always been super uppity
about that yeah you know but we do have
weird things about STDs and what we call
them right cuz wasn't what which one was
the clap that was a gonorrhea would you
rather have a disease or an infection
right that's what they have an infection
in a disease I think I'd rather I think
I'd rather have a disease an infection
can give you sepsis I'm I'm afraid of
sepsis you fear sense I fear sepsis
Errol Thomas I acceptances wanted is
infection goes horribly horrible you
know one set you don't that you need to
watch more house
it's all sepsis yeah old people having
more sex and then look they weren't they
don't easy on the old people older all
right sorry you you 45 to 65 they still
have you sex are you guys in the the 45
to you no but when I get low and I
predict yeah well now they have viagra
too so I think that probably has a lot
to do with it right so between viagra
and then what they're calling the Fifty
Shades of Grey effect that older people
are being more sexually expressive but
assuming that these aren't
life-threatening conditions so let's
leave out obviously the but I mean yeah
a 3% increase in some and a 7 percent
increase in others might not be worth it
I mean it might be worth it did I use a
condom like like buying we all waited
expect we can all accept that and and if
they're expect I figured that this was
really a polite way of saying look how
many people in their fifties are now
having anal sex like but they didn't
want to they specific felt to like oh
you know that a follow-up study that
they didn't put it publish online why do
we get so weird about older people and
sex older people older all right but
when we think of people having sex they
think of people in their twenties pretty
much or there's I gotta be enough I know
there was a point I'm curious this in
your in your porn viewing habits you're
a younger man Jimmy and I are basically
the same generation there was a moment
it happened on television and it
happened in sort of all fantasy where
all of a sudden like the women I was
interested in were all 38 years old yeah
just like that all of a sudden it went
from Nicaea gorgeous 22 year old and I
think she should be dressing that one
right and now I watch some show and
there's a beautiful blonde 41 year old
on television on the cob that's nice I'm
the same way they say that a lot
who men are attracted to has to lot to
do with how older mother was when they
were young so I was born late my
mother's life so I'm more attracted to
women who maybe over 40 years old me too
was 42 and that is literally the most
depressing thing I have heard yet months
you two make no no it makes it great for
me because I'm married now and I've been
with
why for 14 years and I'm more attracted
to her now than when we first started
dating so working out for me
no it's work yeah it's depressing that
you work is what that gets to is you
want to [ __ ] your mom Oh at the end of
the day this is about [ __ ] your mom
it always is yeah well I mean come on
they say when you're in bed there's not
just you and your partner it's to you
and your partner to other people up for
the people her parents and your parents
they're all in bed together and that
they're all kind of commingling right
come on I'm only one who watches what do
you you are a strict Freudian is it too
late to teach older people as or what
are we gonna call them now we don't
people people people these people of a
higher age is it too late to teach them
all the safe sex tricks because they
didn't grow up with that with the sex ed
execs ed and the kids in there having
sex with an older person it's like right
in the middle they stopped to yell get
off my mom you know what I mean it's
tough my lawn but I just want to throw
that joke good thanks for explaining
yeah at home we didn't get it mom I
didn't know I was using it in turn love
lon okay people still do yelled at you
yeah you want to piss off an old person
walk on their lawn or park in front of
our house yeah it probably is a little
tougher to sort of drive those points
home but again if we're not seeing I'm
not minimizing I guess I am but a couple
they look like chlamydia
you know like penicillin stuff you're
completely fine with if you can be cured
with an antibiotic what are we talking
about yeah are you guys gonna be having
sex in your 70s and 80s I hope so
I certainly hope so with each other with
each other yeah that's where it's gonna
go that's where this is all leading the
sexual tension between you two today I
don't think you do an experiment the
older I get I die my desire for sex it's
just my ability right I'm tired I get
you know all that stuff got a boner pill
what have you and so I think I'll always
want to have sex it's just like yeah but
you just other things getting away it's
like my back hip maybe if I stretch I
didn't have a coffee I have a headache
right or I could just stay here and be
totally sedentary like that so always
yeah that's a very attractive option all
right well let's go from sex to
Republicans this is actually pretty good
the AAP is running a story right
about how the younger generation of
Republicans are down with the gays and
they are down with weed and they gave us
a couple examples a college Republican
group leader in Alabama was nearly
kicked out of the party for supporting
gay marriage so that means a leader was
down with gay marriage that's something
the successful push to legalize gay
marriage in Minnesota was backed by
several prominent younger Republicans in
Colorado the spokesman for a group that
pushed to legalize marijuana was a
Republican activist so there's just a
couple antic total things but there is
definitely a sense that on these social
issues mainly gay marriage and marijuana
that the Republicans are slowly coming
along this is good news am i right Jimmy
Dore well this is the way it's always
been right the Republicans the
Conservatives are always late to the
party so I don't understand how we still
give any of their ideas any credence
ever so they've been bitching about gays
forever and now they're gonna stop
slowly and so but their next thing and
then in marijuana so they're gonna stop
bitching about marijuana and then
they're gonna finally come around to
climate change when they're all
underwater and they're gonna come around
you know so it's just like what else are
you got of course you guys are wrong
you've been wrong about everything what
haven't you been wrong about you're
wrong about civil rights you mean you're
wrong about the EPA you're wrong about
[ __ ] every our energy policy you're
wrong about suppressing the vote what
aren't they wrong about so what you're a
young person what is it that's
attractive about the Republican Party in
those stories what's great is you're
right about every single one of those is
not one thing that they're right about
not one yet they still continue to
manage to convince young people that
they're better on the economy that
generic term of the economy when we know
full well that that we address is not
true either yeah
so I don't you know it's it's
frustrating and what a lot of what it
gets to too is what they'll never come
around on is you know suppressing the
vote and civil rights but it's just they
still like it's great a they're more
open to black I mean the more
immigration right bore but but if the
people look different that they're still
they're still not on board but that's
but they're good that's gonna go away to
it after that lose again in 2016 they
will then become the party that's trying
to try and embrace Hispanics and and
immigrant they're gonna become that part
that
that matter at the end of the day if
they do it for principle or for desire
doesn't matter if they make things
better but here's why I don't think
they'll do it because as long as with
what they if you think that I'm being
too harsh about race and that they're
plenty of young Republicans aren't
racist some of them don't know yet like
who they're in bed with right real uh
but where they'll never come around
where the part where they're always
gonna get resistance at the top of the
party is on wealth they don't like poor
people and they never will and so when
you when there's this thought that
Republicans after 2016 will come around
on immigration reform
those people were neat those people are
still poor and may in still need
government assistance they don't want
any part of that that is going to be a
very tough reconcile for them I think
and in that story by the way you see
that like the that that that in their
list that you gave that young Republican
in Alabama she was still nearly kicked
out of the party it was a woman uh but
the head of the Republican Party in
Alabama was still like you know that was
very bad you know he was like that we
didn't like that that was incongruous it
didn't work so I mean like those are
anecdotal stories and I mean they're
moving it's incremental they move the
ball from the half yard line to the
three quarters of the one yard line I
mean they have 99 years in collections
moves them really helps move them yeah
does it I think we could look at Jeb
Bush I think if Jeb Bush is the nominee
that there's gonna change the party on
immigration for sure forever well he
loves immigrants now right when his
brother was a compassionate conservative
and I didn't he say a couple ago he
loves immigrants yes so they said it's
love now of course you know and he has
the he has the Colombian part of his
family his family's married to Colombia
they said the people who come here he
said that they're doing is moral act or
trying to help their family they're
being moral that's what you're supposed
to do they want to comer and working off
their family and we should try to help
them instead of trying to [ __ ] on them
so you're saying that's a cold
calculated political move and not
something you necessarily I think it's
both but it's gonna require money it's
gonna record these people are poor many
of them are dirt poor and I think that's
gonna be a very tough sell very tough
sell for Republicans because that is
that is antithetical to who they are
helping other people yes really nope
they don't mind evil don't
don't write uh wait so getting back to
to weed in gay marriage oh so do you
guys think that this is just gonna be a
state-by-state thing for both of them
or is at any point the federal
government gonna jump in well because
they're especially gay marriage I mean
it's just every week it's another one
we've seen it but yet look they're the
the eventual it look realism will take
over and they're important issues are
making sure that the people who are
gonna vote for Democrats can't vote for
Democrats yes
that's job one for them game yeah like
the Pope like there's a degree of an you
see some Republican attorneys general
around the country realizing I'm not
gonna fight us anymore this is a silly
thing this is a silly effort to be
fighting on on gay marriage like we're
gonna lose and it's done and certainly
as the Pope said hey look I'm I'm
against abortion and I'm anti gay
marriage but I'm in not interested yeah
I think what the Pope actually said was
if someone wants to invite me to a disco
party slam who might to condemn their
accent good accent up shouldn't the tea
party in the libertarians so the Ron the
Rand Paul's shouldn't they be for
legalization of weed and for gay
marriage if they were if they were Ron
Paul was they are well right right but
Rand Paul is not for gay marriage as far
as I know it has really sort of been
weird about weed too but he wants you to
have individual liberty and individual
rights is in this wheelhouse stuff if
they were being intellectually honest
well yes [ __ ] up your whole point Rand
Paul Rand Paul is trying to play a
delicate game where he can be right-wing
enough to get the nomination and that
you know for him it'll be then a fairly
easy track to the center yet we know
that Isis we could presume about Rand
Paul isn't care about gay marriage he
doesn't care about wheat those aren't
that important to him right being a
republic what he doesn't want to do is
fall into the trap of being his father
who appeals to a bunch of kids in
college uh but when it really gets
serious that he's marginalized and seen
it he he needs to be seen as look at me
I'm enough establishment but I'm still
have this little cocoon carved out at
the very it would be very hard for him
so we're agreed though in theory that
already bleed um that's gonna
it's ultimately get a place that only a
member he's also a club called president
but in theory they should be for gay
marriage legalization of weed right
Aryans they should be but is there a
libertarian that is should all should
also be right yet but where are those
guys well I mean economic I guess
conservatives do but social
conservatives shouldn't I mean so review
course they should or they shouldn't if
they're being true to their ideas a
biblical order establish that the
country needs to follow but the
Conservatives correctly from wrong you
know they're extra' constructionists
with the government with the
Constitution's so they would say less
government and you don't you know
doesn't say in the Constitution you can
regulate my marijuana or my marriage so
you don't get to do that I think that's
what a real conservative would say the
real conservative would say I'm not for
abortion but I'm for the government
staying out of it that's the difference
so they don't they don't they welcome
because there's a marriage of those
strict constructionists and religious
conservatives right that's the issue so
final thought on this which goes right
to that is abortion next for them after
these two things are sort of taken care
of is there any chance that they'll see
the tea leaves changing and and that the
huge numbers that some mortarboards and
they'll just stop biting it they'll
stops fighting something that is I think
it's something it's closer to like 60% I
don't think it's changed borsa will
always stay the same
that's all will always be an issue for
them because the science doesn't move
forward it's always the same thing
either you think it's a baby or you
don't and so they can always tug at your
heartstrings and get you to feel that
way so that's why this won't change I
think but everything else is changing
the abortion is a much more
intellectually to get to it as a much
more intellectually honest argument yes
uh being anti-abortion if you believe
that I don't I think it's dangerous to
women to not believe that but it is more
intellectually honest and nothing I
think juries right now I think those
numbers have basically stayed the same
and as we saw in that story young
Republicans aren't actually moving on
abortion they are actually that that
they're still connected to those and we
do know that God is still an
anti-abortion because if you have an
abortion and then have another kid he
will make it a downs baby all right
let's move on
are you sick of your life well there's
an app for that there is a new
called stranger and it lets you live
through the life of a stranger is that
confusing let's look at a video
alright we got a little info there but
now we've got some facts for you the app
tracks your path pulling related photos
from Foursquare Google Maps along the
way neither person has to actively do
anything I think this is the interesting
part and no locations are ever
specifically named so anonymity is
preserved at the end of the experiment
each person has one chance to send a
message to the other either to say
goodbye or to exchange contact
information so just to be clear about
what's going on here this is stuff
that's all being pulled from your phone
for twenty days so you're not actively
posting to it it's just basically
watching everything you're doing for 20
days part of me thinks this is cool part
of me thinks this is crazy you know we
went from like you know when Facebook
started you actually were friends with
the people that you were friends with
then you suddenly became friends with
people that were friends with your
friends now you're friends with people
you don't know and now you you're
friends with people you don't even give
a [ __ ] about so there's this just the
next natural step in whatever this whole
phone is doing to all of us I can't
think of a more useless application as
someone else Jimmy you know it's like
all those people who do past life
regressions turns out they're all kings
it's just that same thing you know what
you're you don't you ever think the
other person is connected to is a
[ __ ] dock worker in Russia I mean oh
there's a guy who's unloaded a truck in
eastern Poland let's book and see what
he's doing all day he's drinking
unloading [ __ ] and then going to bed
actually great we have such short
attention spans what are the chances
anyone could follow through with 20 days
of being somebody else people yeah it
was the Jimmy's point that was literally
the worst commercial I've ever seen
there were five different times that
were said driving yeah yes yeah oh great
that's really old now he's walking Wyatt
where he is it's quiet there is he in an
elevator I mean a car I don't know it's
quiet if he was in an elevator there
probably be background music so he's
probably first car he's gotta have as
well I don't know I gotta figure this
thing out let's set up a message but
Jimmy couldn't this break down walls
between nations you could see how the
israelis could see how the palestinians
are living the russians could see how
the ukrainians really they could they
could just turn on the TV or go on the
internet
read something this is [ __ ] this is
unbelievable
I if i give me something here this is
gonna go this is gonna be just as
unpopular as the hula hoop I did really
I did well yeah I think that the the the
the beauty in it would be in the
specificity and they're bragging about
the lack of specificity like bar yeah
what like you should take naked pictures
of you but just blackout your face right
so that I'll be on for that see what the
person but a one other person for twenty
days you're supposed to go you don't
have anything going on in your life I
don't have enough time to get to these
people I already [ __ ] know to return
their emails they're gonna be tracking
someone you don't even know is probably
boring that's why they signed up for
this thing I don't think interesting
people do this this will fail and then
it'll the six weeks into its failure
they'll be like how do we put a dick pic
component or gets bought for three
billion bucks and then Facebook does
nothing there's those there's a grinder
and tinder and all that [ __ ] I mean that
that's gonna are you kidding me Adam are
you very optimistic that Israeli in a
Palestinian to be like oh my god I'm at
a security checkpoint they're playing
Tetris well I thought maybe there was
something here but maybe maybe it's this
is because I'm a little younger than you
getting here oh look you were making
SodaStream bottles and then getting
healthy with rubber bullets alright it's
not gonna create things I tried I tried
okay kill me well let's move on
is everything decided by your genes the
more and more studies are coming out
proving that that's the case let's just
say that I'm more than water talking
about my job did you know that being a
couch potato could actually be part of
your genetic makeup yeah it seems like
everything is decided by our genetic
makeup these days researchers at
Aberdeen University worked with
colleagues and China and they did a
study with ASAP science and they found
out that that's pretty much the case
let's take a look scientists studying
mice have found an interesting genetic
connection
after separating mice into two groups
those that chose to run on their wheel
more often and those that decided not to
run as much the difference was clear in
their offspring after 10 generations the
running mice would run on their wheels
75% more often than the other group and
by 16 generations they were running 7
miles a day as opposed to the average 4
miles
it seemed their motivation for physical
activity was genetic all right is
everything genetic we like to think that
it's not we control our fate and our
destiny but at the end of the day is the
primordial ooze controlling everything
we're doing
did you guys react to this video the
same way I did which was like mice run 7
miles but I mean the tiny little legs I
don't know it's unbelievable I'm sorry
what was your question about the boy
what would be the equivalent how many
miles for a human would be seven miles
throat they don't have a lot else to do
yeah they're not working we're simply
babbling about god knows what they're
they're out there looking for seeds so
that's like zipping speech being a
morning person and a night person right
so that that maybe that like that's I'm
a night person totally I might kick
something run run midnight I get a
little energy in me and creative they
say most the creativity happens at night
for I was just reading and I think I'm
gives a [ __ ] calm and but yeah I I
definitely think that it's in your
makeup you see fat families you know
yeah it's it's it's it is genetic I
think and um so how much do you guys
think we control how much do you think
is actually breathing you know less than
you think because I read all these books
when about our attraction to each other
there's physical sexual attraction and
99% of it is unconscious you think
you're making a choice you think well I
like this or not you don't [ __ ] know
what you like because it's all happening
unconsciously like they realize that man
that it's the hip to waist ratio that
makes a woman attractive to a man or not
not if she's fat or skinny or whatever
it's all these weird things that go into
it so that's what I'm saying
more than you think you're ginger you're
controlled genetically later that video
there's a great thing about
um the the couch potato gene literally
that your that there is a gene that
you're less you're more likely to stay
sedentary not just that you the
generationally learn to work out but
there's something in you that makes you
want to stay and sit you have to
overcome bat Amin I I literally feel
like I have it is very hard for me to
motivate in a way that I think is beyond
the normal human characteristic of one
is sit around like I I'm worked out in
for years and now I can [ __ ] blame my
parents this is fantastic
but like you have to have it and then
they throw this sort of the at the baby
throw this bony at the end like hey but
a lot of this is environmental and so
you have to overcome that yeah and but I
need a pill to overcome that right so
you couldn't do it that that's the part
that I find fascinating the the part
that you want to sit there and I'm with
you I could watch basketball all day on
a Sunday and not move but at the same
point I could go to the gym and run
around and be just as happy but you
don't have that I do I can overcome it
and I get none of that thing that we saw
in the first part I don't get this rush
from working out I don't I like I get a
rush from competition like try and win
things or lose things but I like to be
involved in somewhere the scores kept
but I don't get like when I run I don't
come back and I'm not like oh man what a
rush what a lift I don't have that at
all you're not a competitive marathon
anymore of a competitive sleeper that's
right right right one of you like an
Olympic sleep that's right you got a
pillow top because just to jump into
that you gotta have some dexterity are
you able to overcome your genetic
predispositions I gotta say I got a call
I got a challenge the veracity of Ben's
statement that he hasn't worked out for
you to tell me that you haven't lifted
that's unbelievable so really that's
natural you're not juicing nope no not
at all he's juicing and not working out
which is an odd thing to do
I've never you know I was always an
active guy worked out all the time so I
don't anymore but that says adieu with
Mike yet definitely yeah I'm telling you
you more control that's why you know
they say the journey of life is to
becoming just aware becoming awake
because we walk through life asleep
that's right like over the years like we
learned that eggs are shitty eggs are
good they're right turns out they're
good uh it you know for
years in the seventies like don't know
don't eat you know too much red meat and
then now maybe which maybe maybe it's
okay certainly for certain people and
protein is definitely good and so
there's bill certain drugs are good some
drugs are bad coffee turns out good like
you know a point great really good for
you you know so but one thing that has
never changed my doctor said it's only
if you put in this per sec perspective
he's like exercise they knew it then
they know it now it helps it adds years
to your life you know I have a daughter
I want to stay healthy and I have this
sense that even that is not gonna do it
for me that's that I think that there's
a predisposition I'm not a crazy person
but don't you have a sport you and Jody
play bass solo playing basketball I love
playing softball I love playing things
that keep score it's just hard you get
old it's hard to find yes six other guys
to get together and give you I was
playing basketball so much the TYT plays
every Sunday I've played for a year and
a half on every Sunday never been there
I got injured like three years ago and I
haven't really returned my injury I got
an injury and took me out so yeah I hurt
my back so I don't play anymore but I'd
like to I miss it I'm better than you
guys I'm at no get up off your fat ass
do some exercise you could watch this
while you're on the treadmill that's
where I do most of my internetting Ben
Jimmy thank you guys and we will do this
again next week